das nur zur erklärung mediation hat
heute berg für die fdp das entsetzen
wäre grenzenlos und das zu recht
ein kleiner scherz ein bisschen ironie
über die menschenwürde macht man keine
scherze eine einzelstimme der
bundesvorsitzende und die
innenpolitische sprecherin verteidigte
ihn auch noch es sei keineswegs eine
entschuldigung notwendig gewesen für
diese äußerung
dann ist auch die frage erlaubt was ist
das für eine partei deren mitglieder
witze über exekutionen und zwangsarbeit
machen
wir sagen es hier immer wieder aus gutem
grund worte bereiten taten vorsprache
steht am anfang und gewalt ist niemals
gerechtfertigt wer einen eindruck von
zwangsarbeit bekommen will der kann die
kulac dokumentation des zdf sich ansehen
hier geht es wirklich um menschenwürde
und meinem menschenbild denn
zwangsarbeit ist nach unserem
grundgesetz verboten und die
freiheitliche grundordnung unseres
grundgesetzes sieht übrigens auch nicht
vor dass der staat auch nur beurteilt
was nützliche arbeit ist sondern da
steht die berufsfreiheit in artikel 12
und auf dieses ausprägung der
menschenwürde
[Applaus]
da ist schon die frage erlaubt wie
stehen sie zu dieser freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung
da gibt es ganz schön anhaltspunkte auch
für ein taktisches verhältnis zur
gewaltfreiheit in der politischen
auseinandersetzung
da muss man nicht nur lesen dass das
mitglied ihres ältestenrates frau hilfe
von revolutionären buch schreibt den man
anstrebe
man kann auch regelmäßig lesen wenn bei
demonstrationen straftaten begangen
werden dann sind vertreter der linken
nicht weit die sagen man solle doch
politisches engagement nicht
kriminalisieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in
unserem freiheitlichen rechtsstaat in
unserer demokratie gibt es genügend
gewaltfreie und friedliche möglichkeiten
sich politisch zu engagieren
wer das in abrede stellt der macht
eigentlich unsere demokratie unseren
rechtsstaat klein und da sind übrigens
keine einzelstimmen man kann in der
zeitung ihrer zb eines kreisverbandes
der linken regelmäßig lesen auch zu
solchen fällen nach verurteilungen
das urteil gegen den genossen ist eine
juristische farce und eindeutig
politisch motiviert
das sind offizielle verlautbarungen und
in unserem land gibt es unabhängige
gerichte da entscheiden immer noch
unabhängige gerichte was strafbar ist
und was nicht und nicht politiker nach
ihrer sympathie und opportunität für
taten
und schließlich gibt es leider auch
genügend anhaltspunkte für ein
taktisches verhältnis zum
parlamentarismus ja für parlaments
verachtung
wir durften jetzt auch zur kenntnis
nehmen dass ein mitarbeiter ihres
fraktionsmitglieds stable sich dazu
äußert dass man in parlamenten uhr geht
um staatsknete abzugreifen oder um als
parlamentarischer beobachter an
versammlungen teilzunehmen in vielerlei
hinsicht ist dort parlaments verachtung
zu hören in diesen äußerungen und
deshalb ist es auch berechtigt zu fragen
wie stehen sie zu dieser freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung in der in
parlamenten entschieden wird
in der argumente entscheiden indem man
sich friedlich auseinander setzt
das müssen alle demokraten jederzeit
verteidigen gewalt ist niemals
berechtigt egal von wo sie kommt und
hannah arendt hat mal gesagt freiheit
ist der sinn von politik und nicht ohne
grund geht auch sie die extremismus und
totalitarismustheorie zurück wir müssen
jedem angriff auf die gewaltfreiheit
unserer politischen auseinandersetzung
jeder verächtlichmachung der
demokratischen willensbildung
entgegentreten und das werden wir freien
demokraten auch weiterhin tun und dazu
sollten wir zusammenstehen und egal von
wo diese angriffe kommen sie gemeinsam
beantworten
vielen dank
die fdp schickt ihre generalsekretärin
linda teuteberg hier zur eröffnung der
aktuelle stunde beantragt hat verehrte
zuschauer beim wenn man die szene nicht
kennt die sich am letzten wochenende in
kassel abgespielt hat dann kann man
diese aktuelle stunde schlecht verstehen
deswegen lassen sie mich das noch einmal
vielleicht erläutern damit sie diese
aktuelle stunde nachvollziehen können
auch wenn ich jetzt über den nächsten
redner etwas darüber spreche also es
geht unter anderem um dieses treffen der
linkspartei am vergangenen wochenende in
kassel dort wurde diskutiert es war eine
teilnehmerin mit im publikum sie soll
parteimitglied aus dem berliner
landesverband seien und die sich dort
mit den worten äußerte das zitat
energiewende ist auch nötig nach einer
revolution und auch wenn wir das eine
prozent der reichen erschossen haben ist
es immer noch so dass wir heizen wollen
wir wollen uns fortbewegen
naja ist so wir müssen mal von dieser
meta ebene runterkommen zitate
parteichef riexinger von der linken der
auf dem podium saß der graf hat nach dem
redebeitrag dann zum mikrofon gegriffen
und dann mit einem jahr leicht
scherzhaften ton wir einige das
beschreiben gesagt wir erschießen sie
nicht mehr setzen sie schon für
nützliche arbeit ein also das war dieser
vorfall der sich ja noch häufiger hier
zur rede kommen wird und wir wollen
jetzt weiter in die aktuelle stunde rein
zweiter jetzt christoph berndt spiel für
den kostet nach wie vor offizielle
regierung oder von ihnen getragene die
drohung wie die kommunistische plattform
die sozialistische linke die
arbeitsgemeinschaft kuba sie die
antikapitalistische linke die in
sozialistischen dialog um nur einige zu
nennen
noch kein einziges mal haben wir hier in
diesem haus von ihnen gehört dass sie
sich klar und deutlich von den
gewalttaten der antifa distanzieren weil
diese gewaltverbrechen gegen unsere
polizei oder gegen andere hälfte news
kräfte verfügt noch nicht ein einziges
mal
da wundert es dann auch nicht da wundert
es dann auch nicht dass sie im nachgang
der g8 demonstration zugegebenermaßen
2007 gab es eine auswertung der antifa
hieß es dann es war schön mitzuerleben
wie am rande der großdemo steine auf
polizisten geworfen wurden ihre partei
nahe stiftung die rosa luxemburg
stiftung fördert das antifa die antifa
broschüre dazwischengehen dieses zitat
haben sie noch mal aufgenommen und extra
nochmal eine sonderauflage genau würden
dieses zitat gemacht da muss man sich
doch fragen was steckt dahinter
und im übrigen wenn es darum geht ihr
verhältnis zur fdp
einfach mal klarzustellen dann habe
wurde von der kollegin teuteberg hier
bereits angesprochen ganz aktuell das
zitat von ihrem bundesvorsitzenden wenn
er gefragt wurde beziehungsweise in ein
publikumsveranstaltung gesagt wurde
wenn wir das eine prozent der reichen
erschossen haben dann müssen wir uns ja
immer noch fortbewegen daraufhin
antwortet ihr bundesvorsitzender wir
erschießen sie nicht wir setzen sie für
nützliche arbeit ein
daraufhin gab es zu recht zurecht eine
öffentliche empörungswelle und in dieser
erklärte sich dann auch ihr
bundesvorsitzender sagte na ja es war ja
ein erkennbar ironisches zitat und meine
reaktion zitat hätte sehr viel
unmissverständlicher sein müssen da
stelle ich mir doch die frage das ist
doch kein unmissverständlich das zitat
wenn sie bei einer äußerung dass
menschen erschossen wir haben so in
nicht mal dazwischen gehen und darauf
noch mit ironie reagieren da muss man
sich wirklich fragen ob sie den boden
der demokratischen 100 und bereits
verlassen haben oder wo die reise noch
hinführen soll
ich möchte an dieser stelle auch noch
mal sagen ich möchte keine keine
bekundungen hier von der afg hören sie
haben hier vor ihrer eigenen haustür zu
kehren und im übrigen gehen wir doch
noch mal darauf einbilden sagen könnte
dass deshalb viele viele einzelfälle ihr
fraktionsmitarbeiter bzw der mitarbeiter
des mdb cebe hier im deutschen bundestag
timm rogler führung tschuldigung
gleichzeitig auch noch sprecher der
linken in münster hat sich auf einer
strategiekonferenz am wochenende wie
volker äußeres ich zitiere mit erlaubnis
des präsidenten
wir müssen diesen parlament fixierten
abgeordneten betrieb schwächen und das
machen wir damit dass wir feststellen
was die aufgaben einer linken sind stark
nähten im parlament abgreifen
informationen aus dem staatsapparat
abgreifen der bewegung zu spielen den
außerparlamentarischen bewegungen das zu
spielen und dann braucht man natürlich
noch das parlament als bühne weil die
medien sind sogar auf dieses parlament
das sollten wir dann auch nutzen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren von
den linken denken sie wird einmal
darüber nach ob sie menschen mit so
einer gesinnung und mit so klaren
aussagen tatsächlich hier im deutschen
bundestag beschäftigen wollen mit dem
geld der deutschen steuerzahler
zum abschluss möchte ich auch noch etwas
sagen oder den zustand unserer
gesellschaft und vor allen dingen in
unseren bildungseinrichtungen dann hier
in berlin trug sich wieder mal ein fall
zu der mich doch fragen lässt ob der
leider in sicht so sagen der spd
geführte bildungssenator noch alles
richtig im griff hat und zwar auch
wieder eine ihnen bekannte person die
sängerin sängerin julie pusch paaren die
ein hit kreiert hat super gehört in
diesem lied für kinder heißt das ich
zitiere erneut mit dem gesicht von
bösewicht wischt man wischt sie den
boden auf wenn er noch wenn er macht und
sagt und spuckt dann springt sie noch
mal drauf dazu wurde dann noch gereicht
ein beruf für die kinder den ich jetzt
hier nicht nachmachen möchte der 121 bis
auf einen kleinen unterschied dem
gruß der jungpioniere bzw der fdj
gleicht und dann heißt es auch noch die
stadt der slogan dazu statt immer bereit
wie es früheren jetzt heißt es stets
bereit das heißt hier wird eins zu eins
geschichts vergitterung betrieben in der
mit der unterstützung der linkspartei
und die spd bildungsstaatssekretärin
bewertet das auch noch als
unterstützenswert und kindgerecht meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wenn wir
über ein wenn wir über die freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung sprechen
dann heißt das auch einen konsens gegen
jede form von gewalt gegen politiker
gegen gewalt in der sprache und auch
gegen den aufruf von
menschenverachtenden und polizei
verachtenden tendenzen und genau das
müssen wir bei ihnen liebe linkspartei
in ihren äußerungen und auch in ihren
taten und deshalb können sie für uns
kein partner sein und sie werden so ein
absehbarer zeit auch nicht werden
herzlichen dank christoph berndt spiel
war das für die unionsfraktion
nächster redner alexander gauland fd der
fraktionsvorsitzende
er wollte denn meine damen und herren zu
einem normalen parlament gehören ein
rechter und ein linker flügel denn es
soll ja die gesamte gesellschaft bilden
es hat eine weile gedauert bis diese
normalität auch in diesem hause einzug
hielt ich schicke das voraus und
klarzustellen dass wir
meinungspluralismus und harten
politischen streit für etwas positives
halten
wir werden uns nicht am herrschenden
gesinnungs gouvernanten zu beteiligen
auch radikale positionen sind legitim
sofern sie eben nicht den rechtsstaat
und die demokratie in frage stellen ich
setze ihre stillschweigend voraus dass
rechtsstaatlichkeit demokratie und
marktwirtschaft die drei säulen unserer
gemeinsamen gesellschaft sind nimmt man
eine davon weg stürzt der gesamte bau
ein
die heutige linke hält damen und herren
zerfällt in zwei teile der eine hat 0
ins wohl ins seinen frieden mit dem
politischen system der bundesrepublik
gemacht und sich mit der marktwirtschaft
halbwegs arrangiert diese linken haben
aus der tatsache gelernt dass jeder
sozialistische staat der erde aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen kollabiert sie
wollen den kapitalismus nicht mehr
abschaffen sondern bewirtschaften und
zahlt formuliert sie wollen ihn abmelden
sie streben nach kultureller hegemonie
nach herrschaft über die öffentliche
meinung und kontrolle des sozialstaates
sie wollen dass möglichst viel
steuergeld umverteilt wird und sie diese
geldströme beeinflussen an ihnen
partizipieren
der andere teil wie nach wie vor
systemwechsel und strebt einen
sozialistischen staat
der verfassungsschutzbericht des bundes
2018 nennt als extremistische strukturen
in der linkspartei jetzt wiederhole ich
nicht alles was der kollege bernd gesagt
hat aber es kommt noch einiges vor
nämlich sie am vergessen gera
sozialistische dialog trotzkis tisches
netzwerk marx21 usw
bodo ramelow der seit gestern wieder
ministerpräsident in thüringen ist hatte
in einem interview mit der ebenfalls im
verfassungsschutzbericht gelisteten
zeitung junge welt
am 23 juli 2010 erklärt die
kommunistische plattform ist teil
unserer partei ebenso das marxistische
forum und ich werde mich nicht zu einer
öffentlichen distanzierung nötigen
lassen
es ist hier schon gesagt worden wir
konnten dieser tage beim
strategietreffen der linken in kassel
dem vorschlag einer dame lauschen
nach der revolution die reichen zu
erschießen und herr riexinger milderte
wie die 13 anderen größtes wiege den
flug ab wir schießen sie nicht man muss
es wiederholen
wir setzen sie für nützliche arbeit ein
ja das muss man nicht kommentiert aber
man muss es immer wiederholen
liebe kollegen von der fdp sie hatten es
ja in der hand eine linksregierung in
thüringen zu verhindern liebe
freudenberg aber sie haben es leider
vorgezogen zu kreuze zu kriechen und nun
beantragen sie eine aktuelle stunde zum
verhältnis der linken zu unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
also jener linken der sie gerade zur
macht verholfen haben
besonders konsequent ist das nicht und
ob das liberale seinen zweifeln wie zu
erwarten akquirieren die kollegen von
union und fdp man müsse den politischen
extremismus links wie rechts bekämpfen
aber in der realität gibt es nur einen
sogenannten kampf gegen rechts
in diesem kampf fließen millionen an
steuergeldern
nach der wahl von herrn kemmerich zum
thüringischen ministerpräsidenten wurde
das haus von herrn kemmerich belagert
seine familie bedroht
antifa und sogenannte demokraten
vereinten sich im kampf gegen rechts
gegen einen gewählten fdp politiker
nicht nur das verhältnis der linken zur
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
ist offensichtlich fragwürdig meine
damen und herren man liest immer wieder
die linke sei die nachfolgepartei der
sed
das ist nicht korrekt die linke ist
identisch mit der sed im gegensatz zu
uns wir diese partei als koalitions und
regierungsfähig
die warnung vor einem angeblich
drohenden faschismus ist das konstante
begleitung geräusch der politischen
auseinandersetzung in diesem haus heute
richtet sich diese warnung gegen uns
doch thüringen zeigt wie schnell auch
cdu und fdp in das fadenkreuz dieses
antifaschismus geraten können seien sie
vorsichtig meine lieben bürgerlichen
kollegen
ich bedanke mich vielen dank
nächster redner ist der kollege helge
linz spd-fraktion herr präsident
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen nach
meinen vorrednern habe ich den eindruck
manche in diesem hause haben hanau
inzwischen vergessen
ich habe zwei politische prinzipien die
glaube ich hilfreich sind in der
heutigen debatte die eine lautet kehre
vor der eigenen haustür und die andere
versuche politisch anständig zu bleiben
ich beginne mit der zweite politische
anständig zu bleiben
die äußerung wie anlass für die debatte
sind von kein ritzing als reaktionen die
ist noch schlimmer gemacht hat und die
äußerung des mitglieds der linken sind
als äußerungen schlichtweg oder ist
nichts schönzureden unanständig
inakzeptabel und einer
menschenverachtenden sprache formuliert
punkt das ist die feststellung es ging
weil ich mir es genau angeguckt hat
nicht um den ausbruch der revolution
eher das gegenteil aber dass das sich
beiseite feststellungen unanständig
menschen genauso unanständig nein noch
politisch unanständiger finde ich es
aber in dieser woche insbesondere daraus
eine politische inszenierung zu machen
damit wird die bild -zeitung zu unserem
referenzrahmen und damit machen wir den
afd kosmos zu unserem resonanzraum und
das halte ich für absolut unangebracht
ich schätze sehr den liberalismus ich
ein großer freund des liberalismus ich
habe mit vor bewunderung die rede von
herrn schlosserei und anderen gehört
wenn aber die fdp hier eine aktuelle
stunde beantragt dann hätte sie erst
recht auch zum fall
thüring eine aktuelle stunde zur causa
kemmerich beantragen müssen und sie
müsste ehrlich gesagt jede woche fünf
anträge zur afd fünf aktuelle stunde
beantragen um diesem verhältnis gerecht
zu werden und dann sage ich noch etwas
schauen sie sich mal die einträge an
unter afd film zu der konferenz in
kassel da steht unter anderem ich
zitiere die linke gehört rückstandslos
entsorgt und weiteres zitat den gleichen
gedanken habe ich mit moslems das sind
die geister die man ruft wollen wir
diese geister in dieser jetzigen
situation in der herausforderung durch
den rechts der rüstung sextourismus in
diesem land rufen ich denke nein
und weiter gestern kann nämlich hier im
parlament das leider der durchaus von
mir geschätzte wahlkreis kollege jürgen
hardt von der cdu folgendes äußert mit
dieser haltung ich zitiere können sie
auch ein konzentrationslager führen sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen
das ist absolut pietätslos und
inakzeptabel und das ist deshalb hier
geht's los und inakzeptabel weil in
meinem heutigen wahlkreis wuppertal in
konzentrationslager wuppertal klima
kommunisten sozialisten und
sozialdemokraten zu tode gefoltert
worden
wie können wir mit einem solchen
vergleichs diskutieren wenn sie wenn sie
die hufeisen theorie verwenden dann
achten sie bitte auf welchem kontext sie
es tun und jetzt komme ich zu meinem
zweiten prinzip und zu meiner zweiten
vorgabe kehre vor dem haus und vor der
eigenen haustür
ja das müssen wir auch selbst tun ich
könnte jetzt einfach urteilen über die
linke und andere aber wir haben unsere
eigenes problem wir haben und immer noch
ist ja nicht ausgeschlossen
thilo sarrazin in der partei der nicht
unwesentlich dazu beigetragen hat dass
die afg sitzt wir müssen selber auf uns
kritisch schafften aber auch die cdu hat
ihre demo und da gibt es die werte union
die auf unsägliche weise gegen die
kanzlerin hätte auch das denke ich nicht
förderlich für unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung der kellner
vor den grünen hat sich stark aufgeregt
auch gegründet aber auch die grünen
wissen manchmal welche belastung sie mit
boris palmer haben auch wenn das nicht
vergleichbar ist mit den anderen fällen
sehr geehrte damen und herren was hier
das eigentliche thema ist und was der
grund und die ursache und anlass zu
einer aktuellen stunde sein müsste
ansteht
anstelle visa während die äußerung zum
beispiel von hermann hartwich mittwoch
dieser woche in diesem parlament das war
der tiefpunkt und die größte schande die
die bundesrepublik in diesem hause
erlebt hat in einer woche in der wir
erinnern an die opfer in der wir
erinnern an die morde an den ns um von
hanau in kassel
sollten wir nicht reden bei allem
verständnis über diese ziemlich
unwichtige konferenz der linken in
kassel sondern wir sollten reden über
die das live zum harley goss hat den
verfassungs waren andreas tamme wir
sollten reden über kuwatsch über
chemische und all die toten wir sollten
hier aktuelle stunden veranstalten im
sinne und im gedenken an die opfer
denn wenn du dir hier allein komme zum
schluss wurden der csu bis zur linken
bei allen differenzen nicht zusammen
stehen geschlossen wie eine wand für
diese demokratie
dann werden wir diese demokratie
gemeinsam an die wand fahren und juden
die die afg vielen dank
henkel und war das für die
sozialdemokraten er bekommt hier applaus
aus den reihen der grünen der spd und
der linken und für die linken ergreift
das wort katja kipping die parteichefin
meine damen und herren ich begehe mal
damit vor der eigenen haustür zu kehren
bei der gewaltfrage darf es keine
unklarheiten und kann ironie geben für
demokratische linken kann ist da nur
eine klare haltung geben gewaltlosigkeit
und deswegen war deswegen war der viel
zitierte wortwechsel in kassel ein
großer fehler und bernd riexinger hat es
selbst als fehler bezeichnet und er
ausdrücklich um entschuldigung gebeten
und wer bernd riexinger das lebensweg
kennt wer seine auseinandersetzungen
dogmatismus kennt der weiß dass er diese
entschuldigung sehr ernst meint ja der
linken müssen damit umgehen dass alle
unsere äußerung auch immer im lichte der
verbrechen gesehen werden können die im
namen des sozialismus vergangen wurden
das ist unsere historische würde und dem
wissen um unsere historische viertel
möchte ich heute zu dem thema mauertote
und sed unrecht folgendes ganz deutlich
sagen weil sie das immer wieder anrufen
und die hufeisen theorie zu begründen
dass menschen beim versuch ein land zu
verlassen ihr leben riskieren mussten
oder sogar verloren haben ist großes
unrecht
und nun könnte ich es mir leicht machen
und sagen also ich war damals elf jahre
als die mauer fiel
ich könnte der linken leicht machen und
sagen mindestens 80 prozent der linken
waren garantiert nicht spd mitglieder
weil weil sie zu jung waren oder viel
später eingestiegen sind
aber ich möchte es mir und der linken
nicht leicht machen weil man mit einer
historischen würde einfach nicht
leichtfertig umgeht und deshalb deshalb
bitte ich heute im namen der linken alle
die unter der mauer gelitten haben
erneut um entschuldigung
ich bitte alle deren familien
auseinandergerissen wurden und die
angehörige verloren haben um
entschuldigung und ich bitte alle die
bespitzelt wurden um entschuldigung ich
habe es in der vergangenheit gesagt sage
es heute und werde es auch in zukunft
sagen für dieses unrecht gibt es keine
rechtfertigung
kein mensch sollte beim versuch ein land
zu verlassen sein leben riskieren müssen
diese erkenntnis gilt nicht nur beim
blick zurück auf die ddr wie gilt auch
heute und überall und deswegen ist
unerträglich was sich aktuell an der
grenze zwischen griechenland und der
türkei abspielt hier werden
menschenrechte mit füßen getreten
im titel dieser stunde geht es um die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
und deswegen frage ich die fdp sind sie
wirklich der meinung dass in den
vergangenen wochen alles getan haben zum
schutz der demokratie
wie war das denn am mittwoch als
mitbürger ein faschist für das amt des
ministerpräsidenten antrag wenn hörte
ministerpräsident geworden wäre hätte er
womöglich einem holocaust leugner die
oberaufsicht über die gedenkstätte
buchenwald und über die lehrpläne in den
schulen übertragen
und was tat die fdp in dieser stunde der
entscheidung
sie verweigerte sich der abstimmung
sowie der einst hat der fdp für die
demokratie aus
und da ich für eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit linker geschichte
wirklich streite fragen ich cdu und fdp
sind sie eigentlich wirklich zufrieden
mit der aufarbeitung ihrer eigenen
geschichte wissen sie mein großvater
waren der blockpartei ldpd die sich mit
der fdp vereinigte mir kann niemand
erzählen dass alle blog parteimitglied
das system kritisch waren so manche
entschied sich nämlich auch dafür war
das einfach nur förderlich für die
karriere war und aus diesem hintergrund
hat sich die ost-cdu 89 zu recht unter
dem motto in der wahrheit leben eine
kritischen reflektion über ihre eigene
rolle angefangen doch dies wurde jäh
abgebrochen als es zum anschluss an die
west cdu kam das angebot der west-cdu
lautete einfach wer zu uns kommt steht
automatisch auf der richtigen seite da
muss ich nicht mit seiner geschichte
auseinandersetzen
die auseinandersetzung mit der eigenen
geschichte wurde ersetzt durch eine
pauschale scharfe abgrenzung gegen alles
linke und ich frage sie ist eine
pauschale abgrenzung gegen alles linke
wirklich der ersatz für eine
ausreichende aufarbeitung der eigenen
geschichte
ich meine ich meine nur wer seine eigene
geschichte nicht kritisch aufarbeitet
kann für die zukunft kaum richtige
schlüsse ziehen und dass das wird für
uns alle für die linke aber eben nicht
nur
vielen dank
katja kipping die parteichefin hier in
dieser aktuellen stunde und die der
ablauf der aktuellen schulden würdest du
dass die linke tatsächlich nur einen
einen redner oder eine rednerin stellen
kann und die linke hat sich für katja
kipping entschieden werden riexinger
sitzt aber in den reihen der
linksfraktion und jetzt hören wir weiter
sondern bei rahmen für die grünen hat
die am eigenen leibe das ddr-unrecht
erlebt haben und als vertreterin die
repräsentiert einen wahlkreis in dem
menschen gelebt haben in friedrich sein
indem sie unrecht erfahren haben dass
ihre leben zerstört hat selbst wenn sie
nichts süßes leben zerstört haben war es
in teilen ganz schwer auszuhalten das
muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen frau
kipping
als ich diesen beitrag dieses video
gesehen habe war mein erster gedanke
hallo geht's noch eric singer geht's
noch was heißt eigentlich menschenwürde
was heißt eigentlich menschenrechte
achten was heißt es auch wenn wir hier
ständig darüber reden wo wir die grenze
des sagbaren setzen wenn wir das denen
vorwerfen den wir vorwerfen menschen
verlässlich zu machen was heißt dass
dann keine grenze zu ziehen
auf so einer veranstaltung hallo geht's
noch das ist nicht entschuldbar für mich
nicht meine damen und herren ich sag das
deutlichkeit weil ich auch in die andere
richtung ganz klar sage frau teutenberg
geht's noch fdp haben sie ihre
blockparteien in der ddr vergessen haben
sie ihr verhalten vor einigen wochen in
thüringen vergessen geht's noch fdp
was meinen sie eigentlich welche
überlegenheit sie haben sich
hinzustellen
diese aktuelle stunde hier zu beantragen
und den eindruck zu erwecken als wenn
sie über allem stehen würden
und was mich am wütend macht und wo ich
wirklich mich frage bin ich denn die
einzige die menschen aus dem osten kennt
aus dem westen kennt und selbst einen
migrationshintergrund hat die am in
dieser woche hier reden gehört hat die
mich am meisten bewegt hat die rede war
die von dem fdp kollegen denn was er
über seine eltern und die angst hier
erzählt hat das habe ich auch von meinen
eltern erfahren und ich habe gedacht das
ist doch wirklich spannend wenn wir hier
über unsere erfahrungen reden und damit
doch auch im ganzen haus deutlich machen
wir alle haben eine verantwortung dafür
dass die tränen dir noch nicht
getrocknet sind dieser mütter die dort
ihre kinder verloren haben dass wir
dafür eine verantwortung tragen deutlich
hier zu machen
rechtsterrorismus darf in diesem land
keine chance haben dagegen stellen wir
uns alle gemeinsam meine damen und
herren ich mich wirklich für wasser
spielt ihm jetzt zeit ist und ich muss
man sagen der jürgen mertens redet ja
gleich noch gestern abend nach der runde
zum strafrecht sind sie doch mit dem
kollegen stratenwerth von der linken
noch ein trinken gegangen
das hat mir gefallen sag ich ganz
ehrlich so wünsche ich mir dass unter
den demokraten müssen wir streiten um
die beste lösung aber lassen sie uns
doch hier keine schaukämpfe
als aktuelle stunde veranstalten
das habe die menschen in diesem land
nicht verdient und auch das vergehen von
ihm ritzinger rechtfertigt so eine
aktion hier nicht und was mir wichtig
ist die kollegin branche jedes eine
anwalts kollegin aus frankfurt die hat
im nsu prozess hinterbliebene des nsu
vertreten als nebenklägerin oder
nebenklagevertreterin die wird aktuell
bedroht selbst aus der polizei
ihr leben wird bedroht das leben ihres
kindes wird wird roth wir haben diese
anschläge die wir haben wir haben
menschen jüdischen hintergrund des
muslimischen hintergrundes migrantischen
hintergrundes die erwarten von uns dass
wir hier arbeiten verdammt noch mal
machen sie doch ihre arbeit und dazu
auch das will die rauslassen als
nächster redner das wort kollege cdu/csu
platz herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
vieles von dem was nötig ist und was
wichtig ist zum erhalt unserer
demokratie wenn es darum geht die feinde
der demokratie zu bekämpfen die es in
mehreren facetten gibt ich glaube da es
sich der grosse teil dieses hauses einig
aber hier reden wir jetzt über die linke
und ich sage ihnen den vorwurf dass mit
blick auf die wahlen zum
ministerpräsidenten in thüringen
ausgerechnet die fdp diesen
tagesordnungspunkt aufgesetzt hat dass
das nicht richtig ist oder nicht
ehrenhaft dass es an heuchelei kaum zu
überbieten
es stimmt zwar dass sich dort alle
fraktionen nicht mit ruhm bekleckert
haben aber ich möchte schon bitten dass
hier mit gleichem maß gemessen wird
die fdp hat sich zwar in einem wahlgang
von der afg mit wählen lassen aber
diesen fehler korrigiert spät aber
besser spät als die unter
ministerpräsident ramelow hingegen ist
2014 ebenfalls nur mit hilfe einer
stimme der afc in sein amt gekommen
korrigiert hat er das nie im gegenteil
ramelow hat außerdem zum besten gegeben
dass er selbst gestern mit seiner stimme
die wahl eines afd vizepräsident im
thüringischen landtag unterstützt hat wo
ist denn hier der große aufschrei von
links sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen
aber jetzt zu der linken nach allem was
uns die geschichte gelehrt hat kann ein
sozialistisches system niemals
demokratisch sein und dem den
parteiprogrammen die linke heißt es
gleich zu beginn
wir bündeln politische erfahrungen aus
der deutschen demokratischen republik
und der bundesrepublik deutschland
sie will also die staatlichen
erfahrungen der ddr einbringen einer
menschenverachtenden diktatur die ihre
bürger ab gehört eingesperrt gefoltert
und erschossen hat die opfer hätten auf
diese erfahrungen lieber verzichten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
extremisten geben sich oft wieder wolf
im schafspelz erscheint bei der linken
zunehmend so als hätte auch der rote
böse wolf wieder dass schaafs gewand
angelegt und kreide gefressen um sich in
parlamente und regierungen
einzuschleichen und zum glück scheint
die linke kürzlich auf ihrer strategie
konferenz die kreide ausgegangen zu sein
dort konnte sich jeder ein bild davon
machen was die linke tun würde wenn sie
erstmal regierungsverantwortung in
deutschland tragen wird da wurde von
erschießungen und wahlweise von
zwangsarbeit schwadroniert es soll der
deutsche bundestag und der gesamte
deutsche staatsapparat von innen
ausgehöhlt werden dafür will man lieber
die antifa stärken zu der man sich als
selbsternannte scharnier betrachtet
dabei wird werden diktatoren autokraten
hofiert und schweigend über die
verbrechen hinweggesehen wir etwa in
russland kuba oder in venezuela
angesichts dessen schreibt georg
anastasiadis im münchner merkur überaus
treffend ich zitiere die linkspartei ist
mitnichten die demokratische muster
partei schon gar nicht die verfolgte
unschuld als die sie nun seit wochen
durch die lande tingelt hinter ihrer
biedermeier maske luft noch immer die
alte rot gewichtige sed hervor die mit
putin um maduro kuschelt und den
fantasien schmeckt wenn man reiche
erschießt oder zu gemeinnützigen
arbeiten heranziehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie
können wir denn da noch zweifel haben
dass die linke zumindest in teilen auf
dem besten weg dazu ist unsere
freiheitliche demokratische ordnung zu
verlassen
wir sind keine witze sondern eher eine
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
angebracht
warum haben sie herr riexinger hier
nicht die chance angepackt sich heute
hier zu stellen und sich selbst zu
entschuldigen waren sie da nicht manns
genug der kollege riexinger ziehen sie
endlich konsequenzen aus dieser
geschichte und treten sie als
parteivorsitzender zurück und eric
singer geben sie auch klar hier
bundesmann park bundestagsmandat ab sie
haben für unser engagement hier im hohen
haus nur hohn und spott übrig sie haben
kürzlich öffentlich hinterfragt ob sie
sich die arbeitserfahrung als
bundestagsabgeordneter nicht hätten
ersparen sollen ich sage ihnen hätten
sie in diesem parlament mal ordentlich
gearbeitet dann würden sie nicht so
einen unsinn verzapfen
wer so redet wer so redet und auch so
handelt wie die linke der darf niemals
wieder regierungsverantwortung in
deutschland bekommen und die kolleginnen
und kollegen von den grünen und der spd
frage ich daher wo bleibt eigentlich
ihre empörung und ihr aufschrei
angesichts solcher äußerungen eskapaden
sie herr kollege lind sie haben dinge
relativiert die einfach nicht zu
relativieren sind ich habe eher den
eindruck sie verzichten aufzunehmen zu
viel kritik aus rücksicht auf eine
zukünftige grün rot rote koalition
wenn sie sich hier wenn sie sich hier
nicht endlich abgrenzen sind sie
offensichtlich bereit in die rote
kolonne einzutreten eine rote kolonne
die bahnen deutschland unter dem motto
verbieten enteignen und das schießen in
die zukunft führen wird
meine damen und herren die csu war ist
und wird immer das bollwerk gegen den
sozialismus sein
wir wollen unsere freiheitliche
demokratische ordnung in deutschland
bewahren und nicht gegen eine
sozialistische knechtschaft eintauschen
wir werden unsere freiheitliche
demokratie gegen jeden feind ob von
links oder von rechts mit haut und
haaren verteidigen herzlichen dank
vielen dank ich will ganz nächsten tagen
war das für die union und jetzt hören
wir für die afg stefan brändle und dann
lassen sie uns in der gebotenen
sachlichkeit herr kollege reden über
eine partei für die gebrannten damit
sieben mehr gebrannt werden sie weiter
halten reden erteile ich einen
ordnungsruf wegen der missachtung der
sitzung sagen dem präsidenten beginnen
ihre rede mit präsident ich dachte beide
männer und frauen und damen und herren
denen sie einbezogen
herr kollege wandert sie erhalten ein
zweiter ordnungsruf und beim dritten
ordnungsruf dürfen sie das podium
verlassen
ja in der gebotenen sachlichkeit reden
über eine mauer mörder partei mit
massenmördern mal in der partei die 40
jahre lang in einem teil deutschlands
diktatorisch regierte und tausende von
toten auf dem gewissen hat erschossene
an den grenzen zu tode gefolterte in den
selbstmord getrieben
zerstörte zerrissene familien tausende
psychische gebrochene menschen meinte
eine partei die einer verbrecherischen
ideologie angehört der ideologie des
sozialismus die alleine auf der roten
seite allein der rote sozialismus hat
über 100 millionen tote in den letzten
100 150 jahren gefordert dazu kommen die
millionen toten des braunen sozialismus
meine damen und herren das vielleicht
unser cfd dazu zu sagen nie wieder
sozialismus in diesem land nie irgendwo
auf dieser welt weder roten noch
brauchen und auch schon gar nicht gar
keinem sich anbahnenden grünen
sozialismus
meine damen und herren eine verteidigung
nichts dazugelernt hat sind die linken
trotz ihrer verfehlungen herr ramelow
zeigte sich vor kurzem noch verzückt
über stalin devotionalien in russland
ein bekennender linksextremist in
thüringen des staatskanzleichefs wieder
geworden der am rednerpult gesagt hat
linksextremist wäre ein ehrentitel für
ihn ich rede über herrn benjamin
immanuel
hoffe meine damen und herren die hohen
ligen weltweit verstorbenen und noch
lebenden diktatoren und massenmörder
meine damen und herren und zuletzt
wollten sie sich hier bei ihrem kasseler
kongress dazu herablassen etwa 850.000
deutsche zu erschießen um ihre
revolution umzusetzen es war ein
historischer fehler dass man hier auch
schon mal gesagt es war ein historischer
fehler die sed nicht ende
am ende der ddr zu verbieten das
vermögen einzuziehen und die ganze sache
so zu beenden dann wäre uns das erspart
geblieben was sie in den letzten jahren
hier abgeliefert haben einnahmen und das
geld was eingezogen wäre hätte
vernünftig eingesetzt werden können
nicht in ihren perfiden kampf gegen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung meine herren der kundige
doktor geholt hat schon auf die
extremistischen strukturen der linken
hingewiesen dass sich dazu weitere
ausführungen weckt die frage der
aktuellen stunde ist wie ist das
verhältnis der linkspartei zur
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
und das hat eigentlich diese frage hat
eine redner auf ihrem kongress sehr
schön beantwortet ich zitiere hier
nochmal mit erlaubnis des verehrten
präsidenten die aufgabe der linken sei
staatsknete im parlament abgreifen
informationen aus dem staatsapparat
abgreifen der bewegung zu spielen den
außerparlamentarischen bewegungen das zu
spielen und dann brauchen wir natürlich
das parlament als bühne weil die medien
so geilen auf dieses parlament sind das
sollten wir doch nutzen was hat einen
redner von ihnen in kassel gesagt ich
glaube das lässt tief blicken und
beantwortet die frage wie ihr verhältnis
zur freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung ist sie haben und sich in
unsere freiheitliche gesellschaft
eingenistet sie lassen sich von ihr
versorgen sie saugen sie auch sie
plündern sie aus und dann eine
sozialistische diktatur zu errichten das
ist das bild was sie in deutschland
vermitteln und das was sie umsetzen
wollen das alles hält aber die anderen
parteien nicht davon ab offen mit dieser
mit dieser offen verfassungsfeindlichen
partei zu kuscheln und zu kooperieren
die grünen und der spd koalieren
offiziell mit dieser partei da wundert
es nicht dass wir eine grüne
justizministerien in sachsen haben die
es schön findet zu singen advent advent
ein bulle brennt wir haben die cdu in
thüringen deshalb ist an heuchelei kaum
zu überbieten was sie als cdu hier vom
stapel lassen
wir haben eine cdu
thüringen die eine
kooperationsvereinbarung einen
koalitionsvertrag geschlossen hat mit
der rot sozialistischen regierung dort
sie stützen diese regierungen denn ist
zwar noch nicht koalitionsvertrag aber
stabilitätspakt aber es ist genau das
gleiche
um diese personen ins amt zu hieven und
da zu belasten die fdp schließlich hat
sich auch als steigbügelhalter
herausgestellt in thüringen dadurch eine
dass sie ihre ministerpräsident wieder
zurückgezogen hat ja da einfach mal ein
bisschen arsch in der hose behalten
sollen und die 23 tage medialen sturm
durch stehen sollen die bürgerliche
mehrheit in thüringen hat sie bestanden
für fünf jahre fünf jahre lang hätten
wir vernünftige bürgerliche politik in
thüringen machen können sie haben es
leider in den sand gesetzt sie von der
fdp und die von der cdu meint jahren sie
machen sich mit der mauer mörder partei
die auf massenmörder ideologien fuß
gemein und fallen auf deren tricks
herein wie perfide diese tricks waren
haben sie heute gemerkt dass er wohl
selber plötzlich hfg kandidaten wählt
weggeputscht da haben sie mitgeholfen
jährigen eigene kandidatin wegzuputzen
haben sie mitgemacht jetzt ramelow in
amt und zeigt ihnen den stinkefinger in
politischer hinsicht so einfach ist es
sie hinter die fichte zu fühlen meinte
wir haben darüber geredet über die
berufe eisen theorie meinen da muss man
an einer stelle etwas korrigieren
eingrenzen und sagen das gegenstück der
linken auf der rechten seite ist nicht
die afd
es ist die npd das muss man ganz klar
gesagt worden mit anderen worten auf der
linken seite dieses parlament sitzen die
einzigen nazis in diesem haus die
nationalsozialisten auf der linken seite
diese links faschistische gruppe auf der
linken seite mit ihrer partei gehört
wegen ihrer extremistischen um kriege
umtriebe verboten und abgeschafft und
das lieber heute als morgen vielen dank
herr kollege
[Applaus]
302 hinweise für die klassifizierung der
linken als nationalsozialist
überparteilich in einen ordnungsruf
das ist der dritte ich behalte mir
weiter ich behalte mir weiter
ordnungsmaßnahmen vor sage ich
ausdrücklich muss darüber nachdenken
ihre ständige provokation des präsidiums
bei der anrede auf die sie mehrfach
hingewiesen worden sind wird weitere
maßnahmen nach sich ziehen sollte das
noch einmal passieren jetzt nicht beim
ordnungsruf bleiben
als nächster redner als nächste rednerin
hat die kollegin sylvia lehmann spd
fraktion ist es ist ihre erste
parlamentarische rede
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen werte
zuschauenden auf den tribünen und am
bildschirm
vielen dank herr präsident für die
freundliche ankündigung wenngleich es
mir eine große freude und ehre ist heute
hier vor ihnen sprechen zu dürfen bin
ich doch ein wenig erstaunt ich wundere
mich dass gerade jetzt die fdp
die vereinbarkeit der linken mit dem
freiheitlich demokratischen grundwerten
deutschlands in frage stellt was mich
muss die fdp die erst vor wenigen wochen
mindestens einen faschisten eine bühne
geboten hat gilt nicht genau geht nicht
genau das als grösster tabubruch der
deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
der fdp
ihr antrag zur aktuellen stunde ist
wenig überzeugend
es scheint sie wollten als wollten sie
die mediale beachtung erlangen und die
aufmerksamkeit vom eigenen versagen weg
in diesem fall zur linkspartei lenken
es ist dem manchmal doch so ein antrag
sagt oft mehr über den antragsteller aus
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich war die aussage der
besucherin besagter veranstaltung der
linken in kassel völlig inakzeptabel
umso mehr hätte es einer klaren
abgrenzung von seiten des
bundesvorsitzenden bedurft
inzwischen haben beide ihr bedauern zum
ausdruck gebracht und sich glaubhaft vom
gesagten distanziert eines will ich
klarstellen ich werde weder zur anwältin
der linken noch verteilt nämlich den
unrechtsstaat ddr dennoch nutze ich als
langjährige abgeordnete des
brandenburgischen landtages die
gelegenheit um ihnen von meinen unter
anderem auch positiven erfahrungen in
der zusammenarbeit mit politikerinnen
und politikern der linkspartei zu
berichten
der brand die brandenburger
linksfraktion hat als koalitionspartner
anträge der opposition häufig offener
und toleranter geprüft als manch andere
koalitionspartner
wir haben eine inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung mit anträgen der
opposition ermöglicht was nicht
unbedingt selbstverständlich ist das war
professionell souverän aber vor allem
demokratisch als überzeugte
sozialdemokrat an wusste ich diese
kultur der sachbezogenen
interfraktionellen zusammenarbeit sehr
zu schätzen
aber ich sage auch ich bin sehr froh das
ist bei uns in der spd
diese entgleisungen nicht geht natürlich
übrigens diesen satz auf dieser
diskussionsveranstaltung meiner aber
auch die strafanzeige gegen die
kanzlerin ziele wir sozialdemokraten
wollen nicht spalten sondern
zusammenhalt stärken mit einer
vernünftigen besteuerung großer vermögen
wollen wir die schere zwischen arm und
reich schliessen die bahn in thüringen
der islamfeindliche massenmord in hanau
der antisemitische anschlag auf die
synagoge in halle der
rechtsterroristische mordfall lübke bei
all diesen vorfällen hatte die spd eine
klare geschlossene position verfolgt und
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
nicht neu schon seit dem godesberger
programm gilt und ich darf zitieren
demokratie allein ist ausdruck der
achtung vor der würde des menschen und
seiner eigenverantwortung
wir widerstehen jeder diktatur jeder art
totalitärer und autoritärer herrscher
denn diese misst achten die würde des
menschen vernichten seine freiheit und
zerstören das recht ende des zitates
gestern hier im bundestag verkündete der
innenminister die höchste bedrohung in
unserem land geht vom rechtsextremismus
aus sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen und wir alle wissen dass
beginnt oft mit der sprache und mit dem
offenen wort lassen sie uns hier vorbild
sein dankeschön sylvia lehmann war das
mit ihrer ersten rede im parlament
nachgerückt und das gleich in einer
aktuellen stunde die mit
rücktrittsforderungen mit ordnungsrufen
mit entschuldigungen und mit einem
großen haus thüringen hier zu beobachten
war das war's für heute das war es für
diese sitzungswoche hier aus dem
plenarsaal des deutschen bundestages ich
darf mich von ihnen verabschieden aber
bleiben sie weiter bei phoenix stelle
sind wenn sie uns hier verlieren was sie
hätten alles beantragen können sollen
und tun sollen sie darauf hingewiesen
wir haben das thema habe am tag als
aktuelle stunde und daraus wurde dann
die vereinbarte debatte so viel dass du
den übrigen 1 argo das gewicht von
argumenten
wird nicht in die zivilisten und genauso
wenig haben wir es an dieser stelle
gesetzt war das über alle die wir von
anfang an diesen rechtsstaat und die
demokratie mitgestaltet haben notwendig
uns von frau kipping belehren zu lassen
dass wir in thüringen hätten seien oder
machen oder tun oder lassen dürfen
weiter munter
wir haben und das ist klar in nicht den
rahmen benutzung ministerpräsidenten
gewählt
wir haben gar nicht mehr wert und
deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht warum
wir von dfds angegriffen werden hier
hätten herrn ramelow zur macht verholfen
das ist doch dummes zeug
es ist ersichtlich dummes zeug meine
damen und herren die fdp weder im bund
noch in thüringen wird mit linken
koalitionen eingehen oder mit der afg
kooperieren das haben wir in thüringen
klargestellt und ich stehe jetzt heute
wieder klar meine damen und herren aber
um auf die debatte und den gegenstand
zurückzukommen das geht ja hier im
gefechts nebel zunehmend unter es geht
um aussagen die im rahmen von
parteikongressen der linken gemacht
worden sind
am anfang welche absonderungen einer
zurückgebliebenen aktivistinnen aber das
ganze wurde dann nicht besser durch die
klärenden worte des parteivorsitzenden
diese reichen werde man nicht erschießen
sondern weil das gemeinnützig arbeiten
lassen vulgo die kommen in school an
meine damen und
dass darüber empörung ausbricht das kann
sich nun da kann sich nun wirklich
keiner wundern meine damen und herren in
diesen zeiten
und deswegen ist es auch an der fdp
ausgerechnet jetzt diese aktuelle
debatte zu beantragen weil er mich auch
gerade jetzt in dieser diese
bemerkenswerten setzt sie auf dem
kongress der linken gefallen sind
das ist das auch nicht ungesund und an
dieser stelle muss nur eins sagen die
entschuldigung für die mauertoten die
habe ich gehört
wenn sie nicht umrahmt wäre vom
gegenangriff auf andere da bleibt es
nicht beim stillen gedenken sondern der
zentralbank motto angriff ist die beste
verteidigung
im stil der aber auch gesagt die ldpd
und ähnliches hätte aber auch als
blockpartei mitgearbeitet ja hat sie
aber es gab unterschiede zwischen der
spd und der ldpd und das können sie von
denjenigen erfragen
die sowohl in der sed waren oder
beziehungsweise auch die der ldpd waren
und viele die aus der ldpd in der fdp
weiter arbeiten legen wert darauf dass
sie ihn nicht in der sed gewesen sind
meine damen und herren was die heutigen
zitate anbelangt muss man ein zeichnen
sie stehlen in einen scheinbar fatalen
kontinuum zu einer geschichte die nach
wie vor die auseinandersetzung die
endgültige auseinandersetzung mit
politischer gewalt vermissen ist wenn
nach den krawallen bei g 8 oder g 20 in
hamburg aus den reihen der linken
diese gewalttaten entschuldigt
verharmlost oder bagatellisiert werden
da stellt sich wirklich die frage
inwieweit die partei insgesamt und
strukturell ihr verhältnis zu politisch
motivierter gewalt geklärt hat das ist
nach wie vor offen
und dabei geht es um die politische
kultur in diesem land insgesamt
sie merken offensichtlich gar nicht dass
solche äußerungen und viele andere diese
äußerungen für die haben sie sich
entschuldigt aber viele andere
äußerungen das bild abgeben dass ihre
partei insgeheim oder zumindest wenn sie
die chance erhielte dann doch politische
gewalt als legitimes mittel der
durchsetzung ihrer politischen ziele
betrachtet meine damen und herren und
dagegen
dagegen wenden wir uns und wollen dies
ein ums andere mal klar stellen und uns
kann aber bestimmt keinen vorwurf machen
das ist der fundamentale unterschied
zwischen liberalen und sozialisten oder
kommunisten und rechtspopulisten von
gewalttätigen liberalen ist noch nie
berichtet worden wir haben noch nie
schlägertrupps losgeschickt meine damen
und herren das wird man hier drängen
können und müssen das ist schade dass
sagen muss in diesem land aber es geht
uns eben darum also eine
auseinandersetzung in einer politischen
kultur in der argumente zählen und in
der von vornherein unmissverständlich
klar ist gewalt hat in der politischen
auseinandersetzung keinen platz
nach uns das nächste hält das wort hat
nun der cdu csu fraktion der präsident
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wie
steht die linke zur freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung ich bin 30
jahre jung in einem land gewonnen was es
jetzt nicht mehr gibt ich habe einen
impfausweis mit einem hammer und einem
sicher drauf ich könnte es mir jetzt
einfach machen und die diskussion zum
ddr unrechtsstaat your vortragen warum
könnte ich es mir einfach machen bei
ihrer rechtsvorgänger meinen urgroßvater
als fleischermeister enteignet haben
ihnen die ländereien weggenommen
in seinem ferienhaus weggenommen haben
und ihn aus halle richtung schöner
zwangsumgesiedelt haben weil er aus
ihrer sicht vermögend war
jetzt könnte ich mir einfach mal mache
ich aber nicht ich könnte es mir auch
einfach machen und aus den
verfassungsschutzberichten der letzten
jahre zu tieren wo teile aus ihrer
partei beobachtet werden wo klar ist
dass sie nicht auf grundlage dieser
verfassung stehen dass sie diese
demokratie verteidigen
aber nein das möchte ich auch nicht
machen das sind ich bin 30 jahre jung
und die schätze europa ich schätze in
europa wo wir grenzen haben die wir frei
als menschen durchgehen können wir die
europäische union freiheitlich leben
können wo junge menschen reisen können
reisefreiheit haben und ich schätze auch
ein europa was meiner generation die
möglichkeit gibt werte zu schaffen sich
eine familie aufzubauen und an der
wirtschaft teilzuhaben
ich schätze dass europa weiß sozial
gerechtes weil es den schwächsten in
unserer gesellschaft etwas zurückgibt
von denjenigen die mehr haben und dann
muss ich feststellen dass sie auf ihrer
strategie konferenz in kassel und das
kann man nicht einfach mit einem
federstrich weg machen auf der
strategiekonferenz in kassel auf ein
prozent der deutschen 850.000 menschen
erschießen würden und eric singer sie
hatten vorher die möglichkeit sich
selbst hier hinzustellen und zu
entschuldigen
sie haben gesagt nein wir wollen sie
nicht erschießen wir wollen sie in
arbeit schicken
das ist macht das nicht besser im
gegenteil das ist furchtbar 850.000
menschen zur zwangsarbeit zu schicken
keine freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung zu machen
nicht partizipieren zu lassen an diesem
wirtschaftssystem
wir hören aus ihren reihen aus der
strategiekonferenz die eric singer sie
ja selbst auch als partei
sitzender linken die dieses parlament
verächtlich machen
sie sagen wir müssen die parlamente
unterwandern das geld raus nehmen die
differenz von facharbeitern zu
abgeordnetendiät der antifa welche der
verfassungsschutz verfolgt wird zugute
kommen zu lassen
und da sitzen sie hier ruhig und frau
kipping übernimmt den kelch den sie
weitergereicht am eric singer die chance
hier zu entschuldigen für die eigenen
fehler und selbst stellt sie sich hin
und sagt es tut uns leid für die
mauertoten und warum ich sage dass das
nicht zu ertragen ist zeigt der 23
september 2009 10 der europa-parteitag
und doktor dem der kollege selbst sitzt
hier mit in den rhein
am 23 september 2009 10 einen tag
nachdem in venezuela nachweislich zwei
menschen an der grenze erschossen worden
weil sie in brasilien hunger litten weil
sie in brasilien
eine hohe 1 1 transport von lebensmittel
bekommen sollten weil die hunger litten
geht dr dem der kollege hier in ihren
reihen und die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende auf ihrem europa
parteitag mit einem großen banner hoch
hände weg von venezuela es lebe der
sozialismus und meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren und deswegen frau
kipping
kann ich ihre entschuldigung auch nicht
ernst nehmen weil sie immer noch kein
klares verhältnis zum sozialismus haben
der meiner generation grenzen beschert
in venezuela wo menschen erschossen
werden die hunger leiden wo 15 indigener
menschen die einer minderheit
angehören niedergeknüppelt werden von
einem sozialistischen diktator und hier
sitzen in ihren reihen abgeordnete die
die das gutheißen die am nächsten tag
auf ihrem parteitag einen banner hoch
halten und von ihnen kommt nix nix das
ist beschämend das ist beschämend und
darum sagen sie herzlichen dank liebe
fdp diese partei steht nicht auf den
grundwerten unserer demokratie mit
venezuela haben sie sich bei unserer
generation mehr als verschissen
billige nächster gegner ist der kollege
doch quartal als grüner spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr verehrter herr präsident meine
verehrten kolleginnen kollegen
bundespräsident johannes rau hat einmal
gesagt versöhnen statt spalten muss die
aufgabe eines ziel der politik sein
ich habe den eindruck mit der heutigen
debatte mit dem heutigen thema hat
dieses hohe haus dieser dieser aussage
versöhnen statt spalten keinen dienst
erwiesen
vielmehr hat dieses hohe haus heute
gezeigt dass es eine chance vertan hat
eine chance vertan hat in diesem land
für die versöhnung zu sorgen einmal die
linke will ihnen kollege riexinger der
sie die chance vertan haben hier an
diesem pult hier in diesem hause hier
vor dem deutschen volk ehrlich und klar
zu sagen ich hab's gemacht ich habe
etwas falsches gesagt ich entschuldige
mich dafür aber was am sie getan ihm
feigheit die kundigen kipping hierher
geschickt sich ver stellvertretend zu
entschuldigen eine chance vertan
und ich sage
an die rechte seite gleiche chance
vertan wer heute und hier bei diesem
tagesordnungspunkt als freunde und als
kompanie kompanie von faschisten in
thüringen und diesem land sich hinstellt
und glaubt demokratie freiheit und unser
demokratisches gemeinwesen unsere
parlamentarische demokratie verteidigen
zu wollen macht nichts anderes als
taktische spielchen und das erkennen die
menschen da draußen in diesem land
hoffentlich nicht nur heute sondern auch
die nächsten wochen und monate und
lieber kollege mertens ich sag's martens
ich sage es nochmal ich schätze sonst
sehr und ihre kollegin auch aber auch
sie haben eine chance vertan in der
taktik von den ereignissen in thüringen
und den demokratie versagen in thüringen
unter kumpanei mit denen abzulenken und
heute diese aktuelle stunde als teil zu
wählen um abzulenken von dem was in
unserem land tatsächlich passiert und
wogegen wir demokratinnen und demokraten
uns ein stehen sollten und lieber
kollege hahn der ist glaube ich jetzt
schon gedanken gegangen auch an in die
csu und ihrem wesen des kanals von
bayern kommen sagen auch sie haben die
chance vertan wieder das alte rechts
links schwarz grün schwarz rot gedanken
aufzumachen und dieses land nicht
entsprechend zu versöhnen
meine kolleginnen und kollegen den
versuch wie dieser debatte allein die
linke im mittelpunkt stehen zu lassen
diesen untauglicher versuch der unserem
land nicht weiter hilft unserem land
meine kolleginnen und kollegen glaube
ich hilft es nur weiter wenn wir offen
und ehrlich miteinander um
wenn wir den kolleginnen und kollegen
dieses haus ist zugestehen auch mal
einen fehler zu begehen
aber auffordern und einfordern von jedem
für diesen fehler der begangenes auch
gerade zu stehen denn das gehört auch zu
einer demokratie dazu nicht um zu feiern
und nicht entsprechend zu verteidigen
sondern klar seine meinung zu vertreten
und diese dann wenn man einen fehler
gemacht hat auch ein zu bestehen
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir aus
dieser heutigen diskussion in dieses
wochenende mitnehmen dass unsere aufgabe
es ist nicht taktische spielchen zu
machen umland gewinn zu haben und
gegebenenfalls bei der nächsten prognose
halbes ein viertel oder 60 prozent mehr
zu haben sondern dass wir hier in diesem
hohen aussitzen um für die frauen und
männer in diesem land ob deutsche und
nichtdeutsche die menschen dieses landes
deren würde wir zu schützen haben
einzutreten haben und sie zu versöhnen
haben das würde ich mir aus der heutigen
debatte wünschen dann hätte diese
aktuelle stunde im sinn gehabt und hätte
auch sinn gehabt dass wir an diesem
nachmittag hier in diesem haus sitzen
nur noch nicht ins wochenende gehen
vielen dank für die abruzzen
danke doch bewohner
letzteres aktuelle stunden ist der
kollege marc henrichmann situation herr
trend liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
ich glaube man kann vieles sagen
vielleicht auch uns vorwerfen aber dass
wir in dieser woche nicht breit
diskutiert haben über all das was
schlecht läuft im bereich extremismus
das kann man uns nun wirklich nicht
vorwerfen und wir haben eine debatte
geführt über hanau und tun das jetzt
eben über die linke und ihr verhältnis
zur demokratie und das ist auch richtig
so
ich glaube
gewaltstraftaten extremismus kann man
nie vergleichen und wenn wir uns mal aus
perspektive der opfer der betroffenen
angehörigen sieht dann ist jeder
gewaltakt schlimm und jeder demokrat
wenn er einer sein will muss sie
entschieden und glaubhaft von jeder form
von gewalt distanzieren
mit dem blick nach rechts war ich
gestern einigermaßen erschüttert die
debatte um hanau die afg keinerlei form
von empathie mitgefühl distanzierungen
stattdessen selbstmitleid wütende
angriffe und das ist genau dieser
intolerante dieser respektlose ton
dieser umgang der das klima dieser
gesellschaft verschärft und ist das
markenzeichen der markenkern dieser
partei aber aber wer gezweifelt hat an
der einordnung der linken und da gebe
ich den kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp
ausdrücklich recht es macht sinn dass
wir diese debatte führen
denn was passiert ist auf dieser
besagten strategiekonferenz geht auf
keine kuhhaut
und ich weiß gar nicht was schlimmer ist
zu sagen dass man überhaupt in erwägung
zieht jemanden zu erschießen oder darauf
zu reagieren fast schon feixend nach dem
motto d arbeitslager nutzt nicht
erarbeitet wie auch immer sei das beste
und ich kann auch ehrlich gesagt die
doppel zügigkeit kaum ertragen wenn die
innenpolitische sprecherin frau kollegin
jelpke die selber sich zitieren lassen
das sei alles kein skandal die linke
schießt mit worten scharf sie haben
selber damals als das thema der afg
aufkam an der grenze gegebenenfalls auf
flüchtlinge schießen zu wollen
entschieden zu recht entschieden gesagt
das ist das schlimmste was hier gesagt
und vorgetragen worden ist und jetzt
relativieren sie waffeneinsatz und
waffengewalt politisch ich finde es
schlimm ich finde es doppelt für mich
und das ist auch nicht richtig und ich
finde es schlimm und das ist übrigens
eine wahrnehmung die ich anders habe und
ich bezeichne mich als jemand der im
wahlkreis viel unterwegs ist wenn
menschen spricht und viele verstehen
eben auch nicht dass hier vielleicht
manchmal mit zweierlei maß
medial gemessen wird dass manche medien
so tun als sei das hier gar nichts
schlimmes ein versehen
ich glaube schon wir tun sehr gut daran
missstände zu benennen damit wir
neutralität zweifel und
verschwörungstheorien auf seiten der
presse gar nicht erst aufkommen lassen
offener unwidersprochen nach pass sind
gepaart mit einfachen lösungen das
erkennungszeichen der politischen ränder
und übrigens sind sich rechts wie links
da ziemlich einig bei den einen ist es
der kanzlerin die flüchtlinge
andersdenkende und bei den linken haben
es auch der strategiekonferenz jetzt
mehrfach gehört kanzlerin strafanzeige
hat sie bekommen aber auch polizisten
unternehmer die sogenannten superreichen
auch andersdenkende werden denunziert
und wohin führt das
die sympathisanten der einen der rechten
schießen in hanau angetrieben von hetze
auf migranten und die sympathisanten der
anderen benutzten in hamburg in leipzig
connewitz polizisten als zielscheibe mit
steinen und molotow cocktails und so
wollen wir ernsthaft eine gespaltene
gesellschaft in deutschland wieder
zusammenführen
ich glaube das wird nicht funktionieren
und was rechts wie links eint ist das
glaubwürdige distanzierung von gewalt
immer nur dann passiert wenn sie von der
anderen seite wenn die gewalt von
anderen seite kommt hannover in ihrer
einzeltäter so wurde er von der afg
beschrieben in connewitz war angeblich
polizei provokation an allem schuld nur
in einem sind sie sich einig habe ich
gestern mal so in der debatte
festgestellt rund um syrien und
griechenland ihr freund politischer
freund herr putin fällt in diesem
zusammenhang gar nicht zur ehrlichkeit
gehört auch dazu dann alle schuldigen zu
benennen an solchen skandal und rechts
willigen scheint auch ein ziel die
parlamente auszuhöhlen
wir haben einige zitate gehört ich denke
das was man hätte erwarten können wäre
offener widerspruch gewesen der
parteiführung in diesem fall der linken
und auch da wurde ihr vorsitzender
zitiert der rexinger erfährt sie dass
ihr heute da sind die debatte zumindest
hier mitverfolgen
ich weiß nicht ob ich die erfahrung im
bundestag werte ersparen sollen ich kann
nur sagen demokratie sicherlich manchmal
anstrengend es dauert lange es ist aber
ich bin dankbar für die möglichkeit hier
im deutschen bundestag mitgestalten zu
können und für wen ist eine belastung
ist der hat die möglichkeit das mandat
jederzeit wieder zurückzugeben
und wer sich von offen
verfassungsfeindlichen äußerungen in
seinen reihen und das ist ja keine
einzelnen äußerungen nicht abgrenzt der
sollte das auch tun
ich denke das gebietet auch der respekt
vor vielen menschen in diesem land vor
denen die sich anstrengen die
superreichen sind unternehmer die auch
viel verantwortung tragen ich bin
dankbar dass es sie gibt ich bin dankbar
dass sie ihren beitrag leisten
denke miteinander statt gegeneinander
ist die devise und da müssen links wie
rechts noch viel viel lernen vielen dank
viele hände ich meine damit dass eine
stunde beendet wir sind am schluss
unserer heutigen tagesordnung die
übrigen kollegen ich berufe die nächsten
sitzung des deutschen bundestages ein
auch mittwoch den elften märz 2020 13
uhr die sitzung ist geschlossen